Well, you got 443 million hits on Google,...
...for Lady Gaga,...
... which basically means you don't have very much anonymity left at all and I guess;...
...pookie1234 from Colorado asks,...
..."Are there ever moments the paparazzi doesn't recognize you?"
I have to be really honest.
People that say that they can't escape the paparazzi are full of,...
...so let me just be the artist who'll throw everybody under the bus...
...and my head of security is standing over there, nodding.
I don't spend money on houses and lots of cars,...
...but I do spend money on security and they never find me.
So no, it doesn't ruin my life,...
...because getting my photo taken is not what makes me feel like an artist,...
...it's being in front of 50,000 fans screaming, "I was born this way, baby!"
That's why I'm here.